it's what I live for to help unfortunate
merfolk like yourself
poor souls with no one else to turn to
the voice behind that iconic character
Ursula in The Little Mermaid has died
her name was Pat Carroll and she was 95
years old she is physically bigger than
mine but she's bigger than life in her
head in her voice in Her laughter Pat's
daughter confirmed her death to E.T the
actress died from pneumonia at her home
in Cape Cod on Saturday in a statement
Pat's family said quote she was deeply
loved and will be much missed one night
question your upbringing
Pat voiced the evil sea witch in the
1989 Disney classic and also lent her
singing chops to the role belting out
this memorable song from the soundtrack
my new unfortunate soul go ahead make
your choice I'm a very busy woman and I
haven't got all day it won't cost much
just your voice your poor unfortunate
soul Ursula became a fan favorite
villain and back in 2014 Pat shared her
Theory as to why there is a fatal kind
of Attraction about the horrible mean
characters of the world because we don't
meet too many of them in real life so
when we have the chance theatrically to
see one and in this case she's a biggie
it's kind of fascinating for us I think
I'm even an intrigued by her when I look
at it you better get out of my way or
you're in big trouble
before Ursula Pat had an impressive
decades-long career on stage and screen
in the 50s she started a show called
Caesar's hour which earned her an Emmy
in 1954
[Music]
she also popped up on a number of
variety shows and made guest appearances
on series like the Mary Tyler Moore Show
mine with me you know if there is
anything I love it is long debates
concerning bed assignments when I'm
standing here on crutches right yeah
fast forward to the 80s and Pat
transitioned into mostly voice acting
for animated shows and films which
brings us back to her most memorable
role
you is
your voice
my voice you've got it sweet cakes no
more talking singing zip Pat continued
to work as recently as 2020 lending her
instantly recognizable rasp to Ursula's
appearances in various Disney media
throughout the years I love to see her
and her enormity because she
tickles me Ursula tickles me I got a big
kick out of her she's bigger than life
and she loves it she is survived by her
daughters Carrie Carson and Tara Carson
and granddaughter Evan
foreign